مين اقل من شهرين كنا ارتفع لكم من اوائل
من بدا الكلام عن الشات جي بي تي ليبرمجه
الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي طورتها شركه اوبن
اي اي وطرحتها لاستخدام الناس نهايه العام
الماضي وفجرت جدل واسع حول خطورتها على
مهن كثيره
وقدرتها تحديدا على الاجابه على اسئله
وتنفيذ مهام في مختلف المجالات والقلق
اللي سببته على مستقبل الكثير من الامور
ومنهم مثلا التعليم اناقشنا وقتها الموضوع
المطولا يومها اليوم
رجعت لعناوين وبقوه جدا والسبب ان
البرمجيه اللي بنتكلم عنها نجحت في مجموعه
من الامتحانات وخلت العالم كله ياخذ وقفه
يعني كده وينصدم يعني الناس كانت عارفه
ذكيه او متطوره بس انه هذه الدرجه وبهذه
هذه السرعه
نجح في اختيار اختبار ام بي اي في كليه
الوطن العريقه استاذ كمان مجموعه من
اختبارات رخصه الطب في ولايات امريكيه
ونجاح كمان في اختبار ماده بزنس اوبريشن
ونجح في امتحان مزاوله محاك كمان يعني شيء
مرعب بصراحه بس خلينا يعني كده للتذكير
سريع عن البرمجيه هي عباره عن بطوط شات
عادي يعني بنفتحوه كانك بتكلم شخص وبتبعث
اسئلتك او طلباتك والبط بيرد عليك يعني
طيب هذه التطورات الجديده السريعه كلها
استدعت مننا وقفه جديده عشان نفهم لجئنا
للدكتور محمد قاسم واللي بالمناسبه هو
بالمستخدميه
ومن المبسوطين فيه جد جدا من الكويت بينضم
الينا دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس اداره
المدرسه الرقم السابق في كليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيا اهلا فينا احلى فيك معانا
دكتور بيقول لي السر
تعبك الكبير بالشات جي بي تي
والله صراحه سهل علي حياتي بشكل كبير جدا
اهلا ساره كيف حالك
طبعا حاليا لست انا الوحيد اللي مستمتع
فيه الكثير من الناس قاعدين يستخدم
فتره بسيطه احد الاشخاص بين كيف يستخدم
شخصيات ومن الشخصيات يطلب مننا التكوين
جمل لهم ثم ياخذ هذه الجمل ويحطها في
متجرني وتطلع لي رسمات وياخذ الرسمات
ويحطها على هذه التيشيرتات ويروح في ناس
حتى ماديه يعني
في نفس الوقت احنا بنشوف هذا الشيء طيب
هذا كمان في قتل كثير من الوظائف الحاليه
اللي موجوده كمان في قتل فكره الابداع
البشريه يعني من 10 سنين من هذه الاستخدام
الناس هتصير اغبياء يعني خلص ما حد يبغى
يفكر يعني ههه
يا صحيح هذه نحن المشكله الحين قاعدين
يواجهونا في التعليم في ناس قاعدين
يستخدمون لكتابه المقالات بس خليني اصلح
شغله بسيطه انا طلعت على الاوراق العلميه
اللي سوت الفحص للاختبارات هذه كبار
الباركزام
والطيب وكذلك الانبياء هذه الاختبارات
مثلا في المحاماه تجاوز بعض لانه طبعا في
كذا باب من ابواب الاختبارات اقزام فتجاوز
بعضها وبعضها ما نجح فيه ولا زال لما
تشوفين البار جرافس تلاحظين ان البشر لا
زالوا متفوقين على ساجده ولو انه
وصل الى مرحله متقدمه بحيث انه يحل
الاختبارات كامله
يا سلام عليك بالضبط هذا الكلام الصحيح
خلال سنوات القادمه يعني احنا ما قاعدين
نتكلم عن 20 سنه الى الامام قاعدين نتكلم
عن اشهر جي بي تي فور كالمفروض ينزل هذا
الشهر لكن اوبن اعلنت قبل كم يوم انك خلاص
لا ما راح ننزله بنخليه بعد كم شهر لحد ما
نتاكد انه ما في مشاكل ما تصير حديث
استخدامه ونشا قالوا هالكلام طبعا عند
ثلاثه والان جي بي تي اربعه يبون يتاكدوا
منها
ولكن كلامك صحيح احنا الان قاعدين نخدوا
خطوات قاعدين شوي شوي شوي شوي نستحوذ على
اماكن كان مرتاح فيها الانسان الان انت
تاخذين من المحاما ممكن تقريبا من الطب
طبعا حاليا ممكن نستغل والاشياء مثل هذه
لصالحنا لتسريع بعض العمليات وبعض الاشياء
اللي قاعدين نسويها لكن في المستقبل
ممكن يحل مكانه بكل اكيد
الكل الان يعني يفكر في كيف يستخدمها بحيث
انه يكون وضعك دكتور محمد يعني كمان واحده
من اهم المشاكل الي بتواجهنا الان انه
الناس بطلت تبغى تجلس تفكر او تبحث او
يعني تصنيف الامور او ترتب الامور وكده
لما احد يجيء يديها شيء على الجاهز ترى لا
احد يبحث ولا حد يفكر ولا احد هيسوي ترى
مستقبل مظلم
عاوز اشوفك انا اتفق معاك تماما احنا هذه
المشكله لازم نحلها وين نحلها في بدايات
يعني المكان الاساسي اللي نبدا فيها الحل
هي من خلال التعليم لازم نعلم الانسان انه
ما يعتمد اعتماد كلي على هذه الاشياء انما
يعتمد على نفسه وياخذ معاونه
جدك في الانسان لهذه الدرجه لانه
الاستسقال سمه يعني الكثير من الاشياء في
هذه الايام بس يعني خليني اقول لك صراحه
الموضوع مبهر يعني اغنى رجل في اسيا يعني
همم طعمه اللي هو ثاني برده هو كمان صرح
ان هو مدمن عليه وانه يعني
حتى احنا شايفين على الشاشه الموضوع ده بس
في كثير ومسؤولين كبار صرحوا انهم
بيستخدموه حتى في كتابه ايميلات الشغل
وخطابات رسميه يعني انت بتخلي ايه درجه
احنا وصلنا يعني هذول الناس مثلا حتى
عندهم احد يكتب لهم هذه الاشياء ومع ذلك
هم
بالطبع المستغرب منه شلون واحد عنده ثروه
بتقدر 420 مليار دولار وقاعد على جيبوتي
لكن فكري
فيها انه الناس اللي قاعدين يشتغلون حوله
واللي كانوا يكتبوا لنا ايميلات ساعدونا
في تصحيحها او مشابه الان اصبح هذا ممكن
ياخذ المحلاتيه لان صراحه وعيد اسهل انا
استخدمتي على اني ابحث عن شخص يعاوني في
هذا الموضوع
فتخيل يعني السوق كيف راح يتاثر وكيف
تتغير موازين العمل في المستقبل لازم نفكر
نعيد التفكير مره ثانيه في طرق جديده
وابداعات جديده جديده بحيث نصل الى
امكانيات هو اعمال جديده غير متوقعه اعطيك
انا مثال يعني حاليا اللي بدايت فيها ان
شخص يستخدم
اهي يعيش انا اعتقد ممكن الانسان انه يبدع
وينتج نعم يعني يحتاج اعاده يعني تفكير
ووقفه كمان في الموضوع للتوازن طبعا كان
معنا من الكويت دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس
اداره المدرسه الرقميه واستاذ سابق في
كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه شكرا لك